manufactured wood is everywhere
each year we make millions of cubic
meters of particle board that goes into
everything from the chairs we sit on to
the houses we live in but there's a
problem
most manufactured wood contains urea
formaldehyde a binding agent that sounds
nasty because well it is the federal
government has classified it as a known
human carcinogen in order to maintain
our current quality of life we need to
challenge the way that we're using
discarding and manufacturing materials
today I'm inside a factory in upstate
New York where new breed's of renewable
construction products aren't made
they're grown this new process is based
on an unconventional source the root
structure of mushrooms known as mycelium
in about five years we do expect you to
be building your home with mushroom
materials
what are the problems with the existing
traditional materials that we use for
building and other products traditional
engineered wood products today they are
made out of wood
their principal composition typically
somewhere on 85% of the total mass is
wood but the remainder of that is
typically synthetic resins that are
first derived from natural gas which is
a finite resource and second are human
carcinogens their formaldehyde based
when you say engineered wood products
you're talking about things like what
people might call particle board exactly
so the materials that make up either the
chair that you're sitting on in your
office or the desk or table in your home
by replacing formaldehyde with mycelium
eco ativ can create materials with
properties similar to fiber board
without the health and environmental
complications even in nature miss eleum
is like a natural adhesive it actually
holds the forest floor together what we
do is use two constituents roundup crop
waste or wood waste we inoculate that
with Miss Eliam and then the missile ium
does the work it actually eats that
ground-up material and it grows through
and around the particles binding them
together through the growth of the
organism transforming discrete particles
into a physical composite so essentially
we're using nature's technology to grow
a glue
so this is what you're growing here this
is what's in all these racks behind us
that's correct yeah so we have here is
we have an enclosure and what the
enclosure does is it provides the shape
or the geometry that we're looking to
grow so we crack this open so all the
white material that you see here and you
can touch this is really pliable right
now it's it's still alive spongy yep
it's a it's a living breathing fungus
right now so let's take a look at the
side of it here yeah because what you
could see is we've got some of the corn
stalks and corn waste completely
encapsulated with mycelium so if you try
pulling it apart you can see that's
pretty tenacious and tough right and how
long did it take to get from basically
raw ingredients to this this panel here
grows for four days and what day is this
this is day four so this is ready to go
to our press so what the press is going
to do is that's going to consolidate or
squish this material down to a thickness
that could be used in the furniture
industry that's for moving any of the
remaining water it's killing the fungus
but it's also increasing the stiffness
exponentially so it's increasing it to a
range where you would see traditional
wood products this takes about 10
minutes to press and remove all the
water and to set the mycelium so it
maintains the shape that we're looking
for and at the end of that 10 minutes
we're left with something like like this
that's right yeah so what we have here
is a rigid board material yeah and this
is used as a chair back and as far as
cost is concerned how does something
like this compare to say why would so
right now this is actually being sold a
slightly lower price point than
traditional plywood products
so far eco vada has been able to make
chairs and packaging materials from its
renewable mix of plant waste and
mushroom moves but the company sees this
is only the beginning to what you can do
with fungus --mess ileum is a naturally
occurring polymer and we think most of
the best applications for this platform
or word we're replacing other
synthetically derived polymers
we only have one planet if we're going
to continue to grow and prosper as a
people means that we can't be reliant
upon materials that can't be up cycled
or reused in the future